- Good morning, Believe Nation.
It's Evan.
My one word is believe
and I believe in people more
than they believe in themselves
and my sincere hope is
that if you see in yourself
what I see in you, you'll be
able to change the planet.
So to help you on your journey,
today's message is we are all stars.
Over to you, Beyonce.
(rooster crowing)
♫ I wake up every mornin'
♫ Entspresso keep me goin'
- I think a star is
born a star, absolutely.
I think, I know me, I
was born to do what I do.
It's just too natural.
There's certain things that
I know, no one taught me.
No one can teach you.
It's just you are.
And I feel like we all are
stars, we all have that.
We just have to figure
out what that thing is
that we're supposed to be doing in life.
And I know that for me to know exactly
what I was born to do at such a young age
is why I've been able to do what I do,
as well as I do it,
because I've been doing
it for a really long time
and I'm doing the right thing.
So I'm very lucky.
- So I believe that everybody has Beyonce,
or what I like to call
Michael Jordan level talent,
at something.
You have Beyonce level
talent at something.
You just may not have discovered it yet
and if you have discovered it,
you may not be good enough at it yet
and you need to practice
and hone in your skills
and put in the work.
And what I would really
encourage you to do
is look at the work that
you're working at right now,
does it make you happy?
Are you fulfilled in the
work that you're doing?
You may not be happy with the results.
You may not be happy because
you're a perfectionist
and because you know you
can always be better.
You may not be happy because
you're not earning the income
that you want to be earning yet.
You may not be happy because
you're not getting the awards
or the accolades from people yet.
But are you happy with the actual work?
Are you happy with the progress?
Because at the start of
anything, you're going to suck.
You know, the start of me
making my YouTube channel,
I sucked.
I enjoyed making the videos.
I enjoyed the process.
I enjoyed getting in front of the camera
and talking to you guys.
But I sucked, my delivery
sucked, my editing sucked.
You know, my SCO and
titles, all of that sucked.
I had no comments.
From an external perspective, you're like,
no comments, no views, no
awards, very minimal growth.
But I was happy doing what I was doing
and I wanted to get better at it.
And so, for me, that's the key.
Because you can quickly surpass people
who have years of experience in any field
if you are deeply passionate about it.
The person who has the
passion, the excitement,
and the enjoyment for the work,
enjoyment for the process,
will quickly destroy the person
who doesn't really have the enjoyment
but has the years of experience.
You can learn anything really quickly.
Think about anything that
you've learned recently.
You could pick it up super fast
if you're motivated to do it,
if it doesn't feel like work.
You can learn anything,
whether it's a language,
whether it's a skill, whether
it's how to market yourself.
If you wanted to learn YouTube marketing,
if you wanted to understand
the YouTube algorithm,
you could pick that up really quickly.
You know, within a day,
you could know more
than 99% of the YouTubers out there,
just by doing research.
And so, I wouldn't get so caught up
in a lot of industries about, you know,
the experience level, 'cause
you can get there faster
if you have that deep,
dedicated passion to it.
But that's the thing, are
you happy with the work?
And sometimes that's hard to separate.
Sometimes it's hard to see
something that you are excited by
and you love doing and you're
not seeing the results,
and you just keep on doing it.
For me, to make 5,000 videos,
to keep on making the content,
even though you're not seeing the results.
And that's why the single
most important lesson
that comes from all of these videos,
all of these people that I've researched,
is to follow your passion, the
thing that you're excited by.
Because if you don't,
you're going to quit.
You're going to quit 'cause it's too hard,
'cause there's lots of competition,
there's lots of people doing it.
It's just too hard to break through
in a lot of these industries
unless you are super passionate
with what you're doing.
And so you have Beyonce
level talent at something.
Maybe you've discovered
it and if you have,
then you just need to
continue to work at it,
even if you aren't seeing the results,
to work at it every day, work at it.
Stop putting it off 'til tomorrow.
Stop quitting, stop starting and stopping,
starting and stopping.
Every day you have to
work on it to get better,
because Beyonce had the talent
but she put in the work.
Right?
That's what you need to do.
What if Beyonce had never
discovered her singing, though?
discovered her dancing?
She would be, you know,
working at some job at Costco,
or Starbucks, or McDonald's, or some job
that was not to her level of stardom.
That's what most people do.
Most people are in a job,
or even starting a business,
that is below their capabilities,
where you could be a star at something
and instead you're playing
way, way, way below
what your capable of doing.
And so if she had never discovered
her singing or her dancing,
how much worse off would she be?
But how much worse off would we all be?
Right, like her music, her dancing
has been a gift to all of us.
How many of you have been
inspired by a Beyonce song
that moved you, that was there for you
when you needed tough times,
or that motivated you to go
off and do something great.
I have a couple of her
songs on my playlist
that I love when they come on.
And so, you're doing a
disservice to yourself
and to your community and
to the world at whole,
if you are not going in on the things
that you could be a star at
and you're living a smaller
life than you should be.
So the question of the day today is
what are you a star in
or a developing star in,
you could be a star in?
Leave it down in the comments below.
I'm curious to see what natural talents
we have in Believe Nation.
And also, if you are leaving a comment
within the first couple hours
of this video going live,
you have a chance to win
one of two daily prizes.
I also want to give a
quick shout out to Chao.
Thank you so much for
picking up a copy of my book,
Your One Word.
I really, really appreciate the support
and I hope you're enjoying the read.
Thank you guys, again, for watching.
I believe in you.
I hope you continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is.
Much love and I'll see
you again tomorrow morning
for another shot of Entspresso.
♫ I wake up every mornin'
♫ Entspresso keep me goin'
- When I was in the seventh grade,
my buddy moved away to Oregon.
There was a week where I went up
to go visit him in Portland.
I flew up there by
myself, go to his house,
and the whole thing was is,
"Hey, he's going to be in school
"on some of these days this week.
"So you can shadow him to school
"or you can hang out until
he gets out of school."
I shadowed him one day and I was like,
"This is weird, I'm going to
stay at your house and wait."
But in his room, there were four things
that were very important,
A Stiff Little Fingers record,
there was a All record,
a Dinosaur Junior record,
and there was an electric guitar.
So what I did was, I would play
those three albums on vinyl
and I would go over
and pick up this guitar
to keep myself entertained
throughout the day
for those three or four days
that he would be at school
until he would come back.
And we'd skate at night and do whatever.
That changed my life you know.
Changed my life.
The hearing punk rock music
and picking up the guitar,
something clicked where it's almost like
there's a bunch of gasoline on the ground
and someone flicks a
cigarette, it just ignites.
You know, it's just, it
was a chemical reaction
that just flipped on a switch
that nothing could take
that guitar out of my hand
from that point forward.
- Well my message to the
youth, pretty much, man,
is just to follow your dreams.
You know what I mean?
I think a lot of people get caught up
and get sidetracked by
what's happening around them
and what's cool.
People always ignore they gift,
not realizing that gift is what's going to
take you out of your poverty,
take you out of your situation.
That gift is the ultimate
element that God provided
for you to get you out of any situation,
or to take you to what's destined for you.
You know, some people are
just great at certain things
but because music, or
modeling, or a film is cool,
they alienate what their gifts are
just be a part of something
that is presumed to be
or persuaded to be cool.
So I always felt like, you know, my method
and message always has been
to just follow the gift
that you have, put a
lot of emphasizing it,
concentrate on what you
feel that you're great in,
because what you're great in
is always what pulls you out
of the worst situations
that you could ever imagine
and put you in a better situation
life than you're in today.
- Your gift can be anything.
You can't look at it as simply running,
jumping, singing, and dancing.
But I tell you one thing,
your gift is the thing that
you do the absolute best
with the least amount of effort.
For me, it was comedy.
So once you identify, then
that's the beginning of it.
But there's a lot of work to do,
even after you identify your gift.
You know, you can believe
you're something all you want,
but if you don't work towards
it, you're just sitting there.
It's going to be empty.